the brand new mayor of new york city
eric adams recently said that he
personally believes that bitcoin and
blockchain technologies and crypto
assets should be taught in schools now
this should be a no-brainer to most
people in the world but still there's
plenty of critics so what exactly is he
talking about here he specifically said
that when he's on the streets and he's
talking about bitcoin or blockchain or
crypto there's people who walk up to him
especially young people and say what is
that and even though they're digital
natives even though this technology many
of their peers are embracing they still
don't know what it is and so his thought
process is if there's brand new
technologies like bitcoin and crypto
this should be taught in schools why is
it they have to go on the internet they
have to go to places like reddit or
wikipedia or youtube or twitter and try
to find the information for themselves
why can't they simply go to school where
they're supposed to be learning about
what to do how to do it what the
technologies of the future are and how
to eventually be a good productive
citizen in the world why aren't we
teaching those kids these types of
technologies why aren't we explaining to
them what is money how does money work
and why these assets may be different
why don't we explain exactly what the
underlying technologies are and how
those technologies are going to improve
their lives how those technologies are
going to change the jobs that these kids
are going to get in the future and why
these technologies continue to gain
global adoption over and over and over
again i tend to think that the mayor
coming in as the new york city new
leadership
has it right every child in america not
only in new york city but all over
america should be taught about this they
should understand what bitcoin is and
how it works they should understand how
the underlying technology works what is
mining what are nodes how can you
actually do self-custody and why are
these technologies so important in the
world it's awesome to see a mayor now
talking about this not only just taking
paychecks in bitcoin but also talking
about educating people about going to
the school system where every single kid
is required to be for a portion of the
day and saying to them let us teach you
actually valuable information
information that you'll be able to use
in your career and information that can
change your life as you go out into the
workforce kudos to the mayor of new york
i hope that more and more people around
the country start to actually take this
idea and run with it every single child
in america should be taught about these
technologies because these technologies
are the technologies that the future
will be built on